yeah Sasha Witnesses tell us this was a
traumatic experience for them to witness
and actually just over my shoulder here
moments ago police removed a tent that
was stationed out here for hours again
like Sasa said this all happened on the
sidewalk right over here a man seemingly
randomly slashing a large kitchen knife
around in broad daylight now what's
coming on your screen is what we arrived
to less than an hour after it was first
reported what would uh one witness
rather tells us that her son was just
inches away from the action another
witness saw a show girl covered in blood
across her chest and torso now this
witness tells me a woman was on the
ground for several minutes before people
began attending to her as the man
continued to Rampage nearby
this guy came ran up and started
stabbing this lady in front of me and
she ran around the escalators and then
she collapsed up under the bridge and
her girlfriend was trying to help her I
mean we're just going to be extra
careful we're careful we have our
brother and our husband with us and just
you know stay together
now several streets were closed off
including Las Vegas Boulevard between
Fashion Show to Spring Mountain and all
the way down Sands Avenue the sidewalk
closest to the wind in Palazzo where
police confirmed the suspect also ran
away from now he or that currently
remains close to the public as well the
other side of the street where we're
standing on now had hundreds of
onlookers watching as police
investigated the wind Treasure Island
and some of those stores around the area
here did reportedly close for just a
moment after it was first reported in
many of the stores remaining open
through the entire game Christian back
to you in the studio Ryan just can't
imagine how traumatizing this would be
for the people who witnessed the attacks
let alone in the number of people police
have to interview
yeah Kirsten it was a large group of
people how many were unclear on that but
actually we were just a little bit
further than the street moments ago
where police told us to stand right
across the street a large group of
witnesses that police were interviewing
we know this because we walked over
tried talking to them before being
deterred away from police but again many
of those people telling us actually one
of those people telling us her son who
was just inches away from the track from
the attack rather is going to be
traumatized by this for years to come
Kirsten